i gotta say i'm loving these i always
wanted to wear hammer pants stop
hammer time no stop joking around you're
wearing those pants to keep your
testicles away from your body's warm
core so your sperm don't overheat well i
am loving the breeze i feel like i'm 83.
all right focus up this is our pregnancy
war room on the master calendar we will
track ovulation windows menstruation
cycles and
every uterine deposit uterine deposit is
that what we're calling sex now it seems
a little clinical well you could always
shorten it to
ud or ed yeah i don't want to do that
here's a list of everything
you cannot eat while we're trying to
conceive no more nachos
even if they're in a novelty baseball
helmet no whoa
this is serious we will adhere to a
strict exercise regimen and sleep
schedule also
no more video games because they cause
stress and they raise your heart rate
more stress than being a police officer
jake i've seen you play mario party
wario cheats i'm just saying about wario
jesus
stupid game look i know it isn't easy
but
this could increase our chances of
getting pregnant by 19
yeah of course absolutely so how do we
get it started dim the lights put on
some music
swallow 35 vitamins each oh cheers
oh that's bigger baby
i probably should have had some water
ready okay
basil body temperature is optimal
let's do this quickly oh amy i'm not
some faucet you can just
turn on and off you gotta romance me
faucet tom let's add
thank you bless you okay this is dania
[Music]
sorry i thought you separated the males
and the females well it's hard
they're all named claire you named them
claire
[Music]
oh come on it's like every woman in this
city has all of her teeth
stupid bloomberg and his stupid soda man
okay 6
14. it's 8 o'clock okay here we go
so this bag of pellets is your lunch yup
it's a perfect food for the human man
you want something no
[Music]
sorry
where were you you're 19 minutes late my
temperature is shot to hell
i know i'm sorry i got detained by the
transit cops cause my baggy pants fell
off on the subway let's just out and get
it over with oh my god
there's so many of them that's it yeah
good boy
[Music]
are you awake no you no let's do this
okay shirts on definitely okay
but the monogamous of savannah
huh make it a double my heart has a hole
and i might as well fill it with
booze same for me except my hole is in
my mouth
it's you my toothless cinderella
well that was definitely technically sex
yep maybe that was the one
nope not the one i'm so exhausted
me too but the doctor said that it could
take a while i know
we're doing everything right and it's
still not working what kind of perfect
person do you have to be to get pregnant
we're having a baby oh
rotten hell
you